à côté de la question au front national
on a représentant ici de la
saône-et-loire vais vous pouvez nous
parler quand même deux de ces situations
comme sur ce canton là où il ya plus de
candidats fn
qu'est ce que vous dites aux électeurs
qui ont voté pour vous au premier tour
d'abord les lits candidats fantômes
monsieur ce sont d'abord les candidats
du peuple ne se sont pas des
apparatchiks
ce sont des gens qui représente le
peuple dans toutes ses composantes et
aussi tout c'est qu'ils portent des
plaintes que ni l'ump ni le ps n'ont
pris en compte jusqu'à présent mais je
voudrais si vous me permettez en guise
de préliminaires dénoncé dénoncé le
terme d'extrême droite parce que c'est
une appellation qui me paraît sinon
sinon malveillante du moins péjorative
je rappelle que la préfecture ne classe
pas le front national parmi les
formations d'extrême droite
nous sommes peut-être d'extrême
d'extrême droite sûrs ou d' extrême
fidélité à la france et aux français
mais en aucun cas nous ne sommes
extrémistes ni dans nos propos ni dans
nos origines du front national qui font
que c'est un parti d'extrême droite est
peut-être mais je vous rappelle qu
officiellement nous sommes front
national droite nationale si vous voulez
ou sociale mais extrême et extrémistes
non si certains candidats quand même eu
un certain nombre de soucis on peut
prendre un candidat d'is sur tille en
côte-d'or comprendre un candidat de
l'yonne qui a fait l'apologie dire et
vic sur son sur sa page facebook quand
même bien cible pardonnez-moi mais eh
bien monsieur vie en monsieur me laisser
ces candidats seront seront sanctionnés
et ce avant l'élection est issu ce n'est
pas ce qu'on ne peut pas invalidé une
candidature dans la mesure où elles
étaient déposées en préfecture me tirer
une étiquette
donc on peut retirer 1000 cas une
étiquette ces personnes seront seront
etc seront sanctionnés excuses pendu
voir exclue mais c'est pas tout à fait
le cas c'est pas tout à fait la pratique
dans les dents les partis qui nous
gouvernent
on s'aperçoit par exemple que des
personnes qui sont régulièrement mis en
justice juppé balkany
dassault est bien continue de pavoiser
et de et d'occuper des place prééminente
y compris y compris il compris au ps
d'ailleurs entre le cambadélis julie
haderer harlem désir
mais sur le fond ce hub sion le fond je
voudrais quand même tout de même les
gens terminé j'en termine ce nom c'est
monsieur l'équipe parlé du dérapage en
termine sur le vrai comment cette
concernant concernant égoutter lorsque
monsieur cahuzac où monsieur thévenoud
se mettent en délicatesse avec la loi
c est ce que pour autant on sait que
quand il ya une institution il ya des
hommes et quand il ya des hommes il ya
de l'hommerie est ce que pour eux est ce
que pour autant ça disqualifie le parti
socialiste et son programme
moi je n'assimile pas les comportements
des personnes avec avec le un programme
et je voudrais bien qu'on désire vendre
à ce qu'on en fasse de même pour le
mieux pour le deuxième